[Musique]
et notre invité politique ce matin c'est
laurent piètre hf6 bonjour merci
beaucoup d'être avec nous secrétaire
d'état chargé des retraites et de la
santé au travail
on est ensemble pendant 20 minutes pour
une interview en partenariat avec la
presse quotidienne régionale représenté
par pascal jalabert les bras bonjour
pascal
merci beaucoup d'être avec nous le
groupe ebra les journaux régionaux de
l'est de la france on le rappelle et on
commence par cette décision du conseil
d'état alors empiétera chef qui sur le
port du masque à lyon et à strasbourg
qui sera finalement autorisé le conseil
d'état qui valide les arrêtés
préfectoraux avec néanmoins quelques
restrictions notamment sur le périmètre
dans les zones moins denses est ce que
c'est le soulagement au gouvernement le
conseil d'état a reconnu qu'il fallait
avoir une règle simple comprend aussi
baisser la volonté du gouvernement de
c'est d'avoir une règle simple que tous
nos concitoyens puissent se comprend
lorsqu'ils sont dans la rue s'ils
doivent ou pas mettre le masque vous
souvenez il y a quelques semaines nous
avions notamment au niveau de paris des
zones où nous mettions le masque et des
autres mettions pas et cela entraîné de
l'incompréhension parfois chez nos
concitoyens l'objet des arrêtés qui ont
été disputées c'est d'avoir justement
une seule règle ça soit strasbourg à
lyon villeurbanne des règles qui sont
simples compréhensibles et bien le
conseil d'état a réaffirmé que cette
règle simple et compréhensible de porc
général du masque dans une zone à forte
densité de population était une règle
qui était tout à fait cohérente avec nos
principes de droit l'a simplement
pointer qu'il fallait être attentif
notamment lorsqu'il y avait des zones à
faible densité et c'est là qu'il y aura
des ajustements puisqu'ils sont dans un
état de droit les préfets évidemment
respecterons la décision du conseil
d'état mais avec l'épidémie qui repart
en france et ce qu'elle inquiétudes au
gouvernement de ne plus maîtriser la
situation épidémique
il ya une vigilance il ya une vigilance
forte cette ville gyan salles existent
depuis le début de la crise sanitaire
mais vous savez j'ai travaillé aux côtés
d'olivier ferrand pendant de nombreux
mois avant d'être aux côtés d'elisabeth
bornes et sur le fond ce dossier de la
santé au travail
il est très imbriqué dans la santé en
général
car sur le fond la santé de nos
entreprises dans
administration aussi dans les
associations et bien c'est un maillon de
l'ensemble de la chaîne de la santé qui
est piloté par aussi aller juste parce
que l on va parler de la santé au
travail avec vous dans quelques instants
mais au delà de la santé au travail on
voit qu'il faut du temps pour faire des
tests qu'il faut du temps pour avoir les
résultats est ce que le gouvernement est
en train d'échouer dans sa lutte donc en
cette épidémie le gouvernement est en
train de voir réussir dans l'objectif
que nous avions c'est d'être sur un
million de tests par semaine la question
qui est posée est celle de des délais
vous voyez bien que d'ailleurs c'est un
peu différent d'ailleurs selon la zone
où vous êtes pour les délais vous avez
des zones où ça va relativement vite
c'est à dire vous avez des rendez-vous
dans la journée ou dans les 48 heures
pour le prélèvement et d'autres coûts
c'est plus long ça peut être trois jours
tout simplement sur les zones rouges
celle où on en a le plus besoin d'une
rapidité de 7 à 7 résultat c'est surtout
les zones où il ya une forte densité de
population
et vous avez raison il ya un lien entre
les deux on vient de le dire juste avant
donc il y a toujours une nécessité à la
fois de mieux coordonner ses politiques
en matière de test mais aussi de se dire
que c'est bien que nos concitoyens
puissent avoir accès à ces tests
et c'est le cas aujourd'hui sans
prescription médicale parce que ça
permet aussi de répondre à des attentes
à des attentes réelles des inquiétudes
qui s'expriment chez le concitoyen oui
comment suivez-vous les clusters siliana
dans les entreprises
et comment les entreprises ou fort honte
et les informations et craignez vous
qu'elle voulait fasse pas tout remonté
bon je crains tu pas que les entreprises
une phase par remonter les informations
d'abord parce que vous savez aujourd'hui
nous avons un système qui fonctionne
bien de contact racing où c'est
essentiellement les caisses d'assurance
maladie qui sont à l'origine de cette
information
donc quel est mon rôle quel est le rôle
du ministère auquel j'appartiens est
bien c'est de coordonner les
informations qui nous remontent
notamment par la branche si vous voulez
santé la caisse d'assurance-maladie
santé publique france et de le croiser
avec les actions que nous avons sur le
terrain notamment par la direccte par
vaux l'inspection du travail et le tout
travail qui avec les ars
les agences régionales de santé et bien
c'est là dessus que nous sommes depuis
quinze jours nous avons mis en place des
coordinations des conventions qui
permettent aux directs et au zaïre âge
de travailler ensemble au profit des
entreprises at elle germé il ya dix les
entreprises y en eut fermé parce qu'il y
avait 3 410 cas de kovy 19 vous le savez
il y a eu notamment j étais dans le
loiret la semaine dernière une décision
de fermeture administrative pour un
abattoir pendant quelques jours de
manière à permettre à cette entreprise
de se mettre au clair sur les process
sont les règles à mettre en oeuvre en
matière de protection sanitaire et aussi
le permettre à la grèce qui était venu
en soutien de faire des dépistages
massif
il y a des cas et il ya eu des cas tout
à fait exceptionnelle de fermeture
administrative
mais aujourd'hui nous sommes et c'est
bien pour ça que nous avons pris cette
décision de port généralisé du masque en
entreprise dans les lieux clos partager
nous sommes avec un niveau de protection
aujourd'hui une entreprise qui est de
très très haut niveau qu'elle est quelle
est la règle d'ailleurs dans les
entreprises un jean-michel bancaire dit
qu'au delà de trois cas dans une école
en ferme l'école
est-ce qu'à une règle précise pour les
entreprises cette règle des trois quarts
a fait c'est une règle commune c'est
celle qui consiste à dire au delà de
trois cas nous considérons que c'est un
foyer à un cluster si vous voulez voilà
donc le jean michel blanquer identifie
cela dans le cadre des écoles dans le
cadre des entreprises n'ont pas tout à
fait la même densité de population les
mêmes organisations
donc c'est qu'il est important de
comprendre c'est que les entreprises
elles ont les emplois ont cette
obligation de sécurité vis-à-vis de
leurs salariés
c'est pour ça qu'elle fournisse des
masques c'est pour ça qu'elle doit
organiser la distance organiser les
parcours les circuits dans l'entreprise
s'il y a des situations qui sont tout à
fait exceptionnelles et qu' il est
nécessaire à un moment donné de prendre
une décision administrative
vous savez il n'y a pas de joie nous en
les adorer le questionnement à ce moment
là nous serons comme nous sommes
aujourd'hui dans l'action mais
aujourd'hui ce n'est pas la situation il
n'y a pas de jauge pressés d'entre eux
blessés jour j'ai obligé les entreprises
à fermer tout ce qu'on vous entende un
âge où je voulais dire le nombre de cas
il n'y a pas de règles automatiques
telles que vous les décrivez en disant
au delà de trois cas je suis dans une
situation de fermeture ça n'existe pas
comme ça
didier un protocole sanitaire a été mis
en place par le gouvernement avec
notamment cette obligation de porter les
masques au travail depuis mardi dernier
quel premier bilan quasiment une semaine
après quel premier bilan vous tiré de ce
protocole sanitaire
c'est d'abord un protocole qui
fonctionne parce qu' ils répondent aux
attentes des uns et les autres aux
attentes des employeurs je les dis tout
ça alors c'est moi je constate depuis le
début de cette crise sanitaire
tu as les employeurs sont extrêmement
responsables extrêmement soucieux et
conscients de leur obligation de
protéger la santé de leurs salariés
et c'est un point on perçoit au
quotidien quand on est dans l'entreprise
c'est non je ne fais pas cette mission
politique depuis très longtemps j'étais
25 ans dans le privé avant et 4 ans
contractuels de la fonction publique on
voit bien que les employeurs veulent
protéger leurs salariés et on voit aussi
que les sarries ils sont ils ont à coeur
d'être acteur de cette santé ou c'est je
crois que pour nous tous
lorsque nous sommes dans un endroit clos
partagé que nous travaillons et bien si
nous avons un collègue et c'est vrai
aussi dans mon activité aujourd'hui
et bien qui peut-être n'a pas pensé à
rentrer avec son masque dans la salle où
nous étions tout seul jusqu'à maintenant
on est capable de lui dire on est
capables de se parler et ça se fait
naturellement donc oui les premiers
retours que nous avons nous avons déjà
eu plusieurs centaines de contrôles sur
le terrain par l'inspection du travail
la semaine dernière nous continuerons
nous accentuerons c'est contre ces
conseils absolument et ses contrôles
parce qu'il ya d'abord une activité de
france à plusieurs centaines de
contrôles j'en ai dit qu'ils en donner
quoi
eh bien nous avons pu constater qu'il y
avait une grande sous les 10 tout à
l'heure un grand respect de cette
produits sous protocole parce qu'en plus
ça passe si vous tes par le dialogue
social le dialogue social de proximité
c'est ce qu'on appelle ou cse c'est ce
comité social économique et bien c'est
l'instance on discute dans l'entreprise
on retrouve l'employeur les salariés et
leurs représentants
et bien en fait ça fonctionne bien ce
truc tard on se retrouve on a l'habitude
de disputer ensemble et sur le sujet un
sujet aussi important que la santé est
bien c'est fluide entre les uns et les
autres valeurs pour le moment ça a l'air
de bien se passer ce que vous dites est
ce que ces contrôles pourront être cv de
sanctions et lesquelles bien sûr bien
sûr que pour une suite sanction vous
savez il ya toujours plusieurs phases
d'abord on connaît cette maxime la
confiance n'exclut pas le contrôle
eh bien l'inspection du travail est là
pour cela mais vous savez moi je je
crois je les vis tout à l'heure j'ai
passé un peu de temps je crois d'abord à
l'explication entre adultes à les
changes au vu des responsabilités à la
mise en responsabilité
maintenant lorsque ça ne suffit pas
disons les choses si nous avons des
situations comme cela ad'ailleurs a déjà
été le cas pendant la crise sanitaire
eh bien nous aurons des actions mots
forts tous et ça passe par des
observations
les inspecteurs du travail font des
courriers d'observation et puis c'est la
nécessité de faire des mises en demeure
ils le font aussi
à partir de quand vont passer à la phase
sanctions nous sommes déjà dans cette
situation aujourd'hui c'est notre
bienveillance de la semaine écoulé elle
portait sur les ajustements
voilà le but c'était surtout pas de
mettre en difficulté les uns ou les
autres parce que tout le monde veut
réussir cette protection de la santé
maintenant s'il ya des manquements et
dès la semaine dernière s'il y avait des
manquements flagrants nous étions en
situation de demander à ce que cela soit
réparé et ajustés nous continuerons dans
les jours qui viennent bien sûr est-ce
que juste le protocole sanitaire qui a
été mise en place est amené à se durcir
en fonction de l'évolution de l'épidémie
il est évolutif vous l'avez vu c'est un
protocole général je travaillais déjà
dessus
au mois de mai la première mouture date
du 3 mai il a déjà évolué il a évolué
fin juin
il y à une mouture du 24 juin puis
ensuite début août il a encore évolué au
regard des informations que nous avons
sur le virus et sur la situation de
l'épidémie dans notre pays donc à votre
question est ce que ce protocole peut
évoluer
oui il peut évoluer au regard de la
situation sanitaire de notre
connaissance du virus
un mot sur l'a14 haine qui était
préconisé un jusqu'à maintenant est-ce
que le gouvernement va réduire ce délai
de 14 m c'est un sujet de réflexion et l
instruction olivier ferrand est à la
manoeuvre sur le sujet avec ses équipes
au ministère des solidarités et de la
santé vous avez entendu un symptôme
d'épidémiologistes expliqué que en fait
au delà de dix jours il y avait vraiment
très très peu de possibilités de
contamination
tout cela doit être instruit de façon
extrêmement précise et ce sera le cas
avant qu'une décision soit prise
un dernier mot sur ce sujet et ses
parents qui s'inquiètent d'une
éventuelle fermeture des classes de
leurs enfants est ce qui a des
conséquences pour leur travail
est ce que le gouvernement réfléchisse à
un congé spécifique pour ces parents qui
seraient obligés garder leurs enfants
qui ne peuvent pas aller à l'école
bon il y avait des dispositions qui
existait dans l'ancien l'ancienne
période que nous avons vécu en matière
de déconfinement syli a besoin de porter
une attention particulière sur ces
sujets là bien sûr que le gouvernement
le fera
nous sommes quand même dans des
situations qui sont relativement
modestes en matière de nombre
aujourd'hui
eh bien nous allons nous serons toujours
attentifs à une éventuelle évolution
je l'aï dit tout à l'heure pour le
protocole c'est vrai pour le quotidien
de la vie de nos concitoyens
allez on va passer aux plans de relance
et notamment la question oui donc huit
cent mille emplois qui vont disparaître
nous annonce l'insee avant la fin de
l'année cent soixante mille créations
teinte jean castex
c'est du moins le pari qui fait comment
fait-on pour éviter un chômage de masse
et surtout pour accueillir les 7,5 me
lejeune qui sont en train d'arriver sur
le marché du travail
bon en quelques secondes et déjà
tracer le portrait de la situation
difficile ça vous évite de vrai mais en
même temps c'est important que vous
l'ayez fait parce que effectivement il y
à un risque que nous soyons devant la
plus grosse crise économique et sociale
de notre siècle et c'est pour ça que dès
le début gouvernement a pris des mesures
notamment en matière d'activité
partielle pour protéger leurs revenus de
nos concitoyens qu'ils étaient confinés
pour continuer à le protéger par rapport
à ceux qui travaillent dans des secteurs
d'activité où il y à une sous-activité
où il n'y a pas nécessité de les faire
rentrer au travail c'est pour cela que
nous avons pris ces mesures aussi
vis-à-vis des entreprises notamment ont
fait le prêt est garanti par l'état les
exonérations ou les reports de charges
sociales
tout cela a une visée très clair c'est à
la fois protéger nos entreprises et
protéger nos travailleurs parce que nous
avons besoin de cette dynamique commune
c'est parce que je lui ai dit tout à
l'heure quand on a parlé de la santé au
travail
c'est parce que je suis rassuré quand je
vais au travail parce que je sais que le
port du masque pour moi comme pour mes
collègues est imposé dans un lieu clos
partagé que je peux aller travailler
sereinement
donc nous avons besoin premièrement de
créer les conditions sanitaires d'une
activité sereine et c'est ce que nous
faisons aujourd'hui dans le cadre du
protocole et c'est ce qui contribuera
aussi à éviter d'avoir un certain nombre
d'entreprises qui subissent des
défaillances et s'il ya des défaillances
vous l'avez dit eh bien il ya des
dispositifs d'accompagnement pour les
entreprises j'en ai parlé aussi pour les
salariés puisque l'activité partielle de
longue durée
c'est ce que ce mot dollars cette
allemande ce qu'avait réussi
les allemands en 2008 2010 ce que nous
n'avions pas réussi ses terres protéger
nos emplois quand il y à une
sous-activité plutôt que d'amener les
entreprises à licencier
il faut leur permettre de la personne
dans les avions et dans les traire air
france sncf vont pas faire voler des
avions avec des personnels à bord donc
comment on fait si l'activité ne repart
pas et puis aussi comment le fait-on
pour sortir cette épargne eux il faut le
rappeler les français épargnent et 100
milliards de plus que l'an dernier à la
date où nous sommes donc comment on fait
pour relancer cette activité et pour
faire dépenser cette épargne
bon je crois vous avoir répondu mais
j'entends pas suffisamment sur les
situations notamment aéronautiques
non non c'est un exemple j'entends bien
c'est que ces amours donné dans une
entreprise
l'activité partielle c'est une réponse
n'est pas une réponse qui peut plaire en
deux ans ou cinq ans il a cogné vous
savez l'aéronautique ne pas de rebondir
c'est quand même un bon exemple parce
que ça peut être
il peut y avoir aussi des choix un
moment donné les choix d'entreprises
aussi des choix des travailleurs des
salariés de se réorienter dans des
secteurs d'avenir de serre d'ailleurs
l'objet d'une grande partie des 15
milliards d'euros ils sont mis sur la
table dans ce plan de relance
spécifiquement dédiés par l'eau sur
l'emploi il ya une grande partie ces
quinze bières qu'ils vont notamment au
fonds national pour l'emploi qui doit
permettre à nos concitoyens de se
réorienter professionnellement parce que
ça aussi c'est une possibilité qu'il
faut entendre lorsque nous sommes dans
des secteurs aujourd'hui nous voyons une
contraction durable de l'activité est
bien renforçons nos compétences en tant
que salarié en train de travailleurs sur
d'autres secteurs où il ya des
possibilités et c'est l'objet des
actions qui sont mises en place tant au
niveau de pôle emploi que de l'ensemble
des partenaires qui travaillent sur le
sujet de l'emploi et de la compétence
100 milliards mis sur la table pour ce
plan de relance une dette et un déficit
qui se creuse et va falloir rembourser
un moment pas de hausse d'impôt durant
ce quinquennat a répété jean castex est
ce que ce sont les retraités qui vont
payer l'addition bien je pense qu'il
faut regarder les choses sereinement
il ya une réalité exceptionnel
exceptionnel la crise sanitaire
c'est tout allons parler des 100
milliards du plan de relance dont on
rappelle que 40 % sont issus aussi
l'europe et c'est important de voir
comment l'europe est là un rôle de
soutien aux économies nationales
regardons les choses sereinement c'est
plus de 470 milliards plus de 470
milliards qui au total ont été engagés
sous différentes formes de prêts mais
aussi d'être direct to tard je parlais
de l'activité partielle de longue durée
mais aussi c'est pas c'est pas anodin
quand on est dans une famille modeste et
qu'on a vu son allocation de rentrée
scolaire augmenté de 100 euros pour
approcher les 500 euros en fonction de
l'âge de notre enfant il y a un certain
nombre d'actions fait pas le
gouvernement pour à la fois protéger les
entreprises mais aussi créer cette
dynamique de croissance de consommation
c'est pour répondre à votre deuxième
partie de questions tout à l'heure sur
sur les paris et qu'il a payé la réalité
de ces sommes
et bien c'est qu'elles sont liées au
budget de l'état c'est à dire à nous
tous l'état c'est nous tous
eh bien nous avons une consolidation
vous avez vu notamment que les
parlementaires ont décidé pour une
partie de la dette sociale liée au co
vide de le transférer au niveau de la
cades est ce de manière à ce qu'il y ait
un étalement du paiement de cette dette
et puis évidemment nous avons ce plan
que nous avons évoqué de 200 milliards
dont 40 milliards qui nous viennent de
leur don qui va payer notre collectivité
qui paye au final tu nous regardes ce
matin vous pouvez leur garantir qu'il
n'y aura pas de baisse de leur pension
d'ici la fin du quinquennat
mais si la question c'est de baisser les
pensions nous avons déjà échangé je
crois je me demande si c'était pas dans
studio avec vous sur ce sujet là nous
avons déjà demandé des efforts
contributive retraités
nous avons entendu vous l'avez vu
d'ailleurs que cet effort doit être
modulée en fonction du niveau de pension
lorsque nous sommes au delà de 2000
euros de pension je crois que la
situation était claire on pouvait
demander un effort lorsque nous étions
en dessous ce n'était pas le cas ce
n'est pas aujourd'hui la décision qui a
été prise par le gouvernement
donc pas d'effort supplémentaire
demandée retraités je vous réponds très
tranquille pour ce n'est pas la décision
qui a été prise au joli programme en
question qui peut paraître saugrenue
mais quand même si on dit bains de mer
ou alors on anticipe la retraite de
temps de milliers de français
saleh va libérer forcément des places
sur le marché de l'emploi donc est ce
bien le moment de prolonger la durée de
cotisation et le fait de devoir
travailler plus longtemps alors qu'on a
des tas de jeunes qui vont pousser à la
porte dans les jours qui viennent
écoutez je vois avec intérêt la la
l'explication du premier ministre sur ce
sujet dans une interview radio de la
semaine dernière et je pense que vous
avez eu raison il ya pardon pour la
boutade mais je sais ce que je veux
retenir là c'est que fillon le premier
ministre a notamment pointé la forme
d'incohérence économique court terme kg
hl pourrait y avoir à dire aux
entreprises
maintenez vous dans l'emploi des
personnes qui sont arrivées au moment de
prendre leur retraite
et puis en même temps nous versons des
primes pour accueillir ces 750 mille
jeunes qui sortent du système de
formation pour rentrer aujourd'hui sur
le marché du travail
donc c'est plus globalement la question
du financement que vous pouviez tout à
l'heure même si là on fait un focus sur
les retraites ce sujet là il va être
documenté notamment par les travaux du
cor
c'est au conseil d'orientation des
retraites cor ministre a demandé à avoir
un état des lieux on puisse notamment
identifier ce qui est du domaine du
déficit structurel de notre système de
retraite qui existent et aussi ce qui
est du domaine du déficit conjoncturel
qui alliait notamment une perte de
recettes liée à la crise sanitaire
e regardez aujourd'hui les chiffres qui
sont d'un déficit déficit structurel
autour de 4 milliards pour cette année
telles qu'elles avaient été prévues et
qui pourrait dépasser les 25 milliards
dans un déficit plus conjoncturelle liée
à la crise sanitaire nous allons
regarder ce que va nous rendre le corps
et nous pourrons après le 8 octobre être
à même de faire des propositions
ça va changer la remise du rapport du
conseil d'orientation des retraites
c'est le 8 octobre
il ya une première séquence de 8 octobre
parce qu'ils ont des séquences dites
plénière le corps où je siégeais encore
il ya quelques mois
et puis ils ont aussi les séquences de
travail a un qui ripe séquence plénière
donc c'est qu'on se tenir le 8 octobre
ils ont aussi quelques jours c'est là
qu'ils attendaient le rapport doit
l'être dans cet exemple le cas ce serait
dans ces moments là oui est-ce que du
coup et vous puisque vous parlez de
structurel as qu'une réforme
structurelle des retraites va être
nécessaire mais c'est la fin de
quinquennat pour rééquilibrer les
comptes
donc on a dit de choisir un aspect dit
on va prendre le terme comme ça
paramétrique parce qu il l a souvent été
utilisée et puis le terme systémique
cette réforme en profondeur en
profondeur je joue c'est il faut
regarder les choses aussi très
tranquillement je l' ai dit tout à
l'heure j'ai donné quelques ordre d'idée
quand même sur les écarts qu'il y avait
dedans dont le l'équilibré budgétaire
qui est surtout un déséquilibre
budgétaire pour les pour les retraites
au regard de ce que nous avons vécu dans
la crise sanitaire
nous aurons des éléments plus précis
avec le corps et nous serons à même
d'échanger que les partenaires sociaux
sur les voies à choisir en la matière
mais discret partenaires sociaux vont
reprendre dès le mois d'octobre d'après
le rapport du cor sont tous les cas les
discussions entre les partenaires
sociaux
elle l'aurait avoir du sens donc il faut
qu'elles soient étayées il faut qu'il y
ait des éléments concrets à partager
donc quand nous aurons le rapport du cor
nous aurons déjà des éléments sur lequel
nous pourrons travailler avec eux mais
aussi la réflexion qu'il ya puisque
votre question c'est paramétrique ou
systémique est bien la question qui s
est il faut que nous trouvions les
moyens d'avoir durablement un système de
retraite à l'équilibré je me suis
beaucoup prononcer sur ce sujet puisque
j'ai défendu la notion qui sur le fond
est bien comprise par nos concitoyens
d'âge des kills via un âge où système
est à l' équilibre on le comprend bien
c'est la joue bien le volume des
recettes des cotisations équilibre celui
des dépenses les pensions j'ai défendu
ce dispositif là nous sommes aujourd'hui
dans une situation nous sommes tous
concentrés sur la reprise sur l'emploi
ou interrogé beaucoup sur le plan de
relance bien c'est ça qui est
prioritaire et le premier ministre et je
crois que l'a dit avec une phrase moins
que j'aime bien on ne va pas mettre la
poussière sous le tapis
maintenant il y a je crois un temps pour
tout aujourd'hui c'est de se concentrer
fortement sur la relance de l'activité
sur la bonne santé nos entreprises sur
la protection des travailleurs
nous verrons temps voulu quand il faudra
longtemps avant c'est surtout les
séquences et canaccord et je me suis
aussi exprimé sur le sujet mais vous
savez le président de la république et
premiers se sont exprimés donc ya pas de
surprise quand je dis je jouerai affirme
que nous ferons cela avant la fin du
quinquennat c'est parce que mais c'est
juste pour finir qu'on soit car quelle
réforme des retraites quand jean castex
dit la réforme des retraites sera
poursuivie c'est quelle réforme des
retraites on se souvient que emmanuel
macron lors de sa campagne avait
envisagé cette réforme systémique parce
qu'il n'y avait pas de problème des
qualifs du système aujourd'hui c'est
loin d'être le cas est ce que la réforme
telle qu'envisagée au début du
quinquennat va pouvoir être faisable
la réforme systémique est les deux tons
plus utile la réforme de fond elle est
d'autant plus utile
on l'a bien vu là avec cette crise
sanitaire tous et où tous nos
concitoyens qui sont ce qu'on appelle en
deuxième ligne
les livreurs les hôtesses de caisse les
employés ce qu'on fait nous attendre et
attendre c'est eux qui sont les grands
perdants du système actuel et bien c'est
pour eux qu'il faut faire cette
transformation parce que nous ce que
nous voulons c'est plus de justice et
d'équité
et si nous considérons que la retraite
sur le fond est une forme de
rémunération différée que nous percevons
au moment où nous travaillons plus et
bien il faut aussi que pour tous ceux là
qui sont en premier rallye
on deuxième lors justement bien une
restitution pour cette deuxième oui
puisqu'on parle de ses salariés de
deuxième ligne qui n'ont pas eu comme
les soignants comme les électriciens
comme d'autres qui n'ont pas eu de prime
ils n'ont pas eu grand chose pour le
moment
bon certes on voit bien que la réforme
des retraites va en effet les avantages
et met immédiatement
on n'a pas vu dans le plan de relance
des mesures pour soutenir le pouvoir
d'achat
allez-vous leur proposer quelque chose
et quoi je crois que je dois faire pour
justin vous dire que je suis pas
d'accord avec vous sur la première
partie sur les soignants le moins qu'on
puisse dire c'est que oui c'est ce que
j'avais connu ont été soignés en
revanche je parlais de la deuxième ligne
c'est à dire donc vous et d'aidés
soignants et voilà hélas et entraîne les
livreurs ceux que vous avez cités pense
que c'est un des leviers ce n'est pas
seul mais c'est un des leviers qui doit
nous pousser à transformer notre système
de retraite puisque c'est eux qui seront
je fais il ya ceux qui en trente cinq
grandes mailles va falloir patienter un
certain nombre de primes qui sont à la
décision des entreprises mais vous savez
qu'on a notamment profondément
bouleversé la structuration de la
rémunération en donnant les possibilités
aux entreprises de faire de
l'intéressement et la participation
une clé de leur rémunération moi je
crois beaucoup partage de la valeur
ajoutée et partager la valeur ajoutée
créée une entreprise ça doit se faire en
cohérence et on partage avec les
salariés
et merci beaucoup laurent piètre hs qui
devraient être avec nous viendrait nous
parler en cette réforme des retraites
une fois le rapport du cor vomi merci
d'avoir été avec nous demain votre place
ce sera votre collègue de brigitte
klinkert ministre délégué chargé de
l'insertion merci pascal on passe
aussitôt club des territoires